it took a few days but boris johnson is
now the second world leader to speak
with the president-elect
joe biden making clear he wants the
british government
to respect the good friday agreement in
any brexit deal
taking questions on his outlook and his
opponent
for the first time i'm letting him know
that america is back
we're going to be back in the game it's
not american alone
number one i've got had the opportunity
to speak
with now six world leaders
and and the response has been
very fulsome energetic
sir what do you say to the americans
that are anxious over the fact that
president trump has yet to concede and
what that might mean for the country
well um i just think it's an
embarrassment
quite frankly the only thing that
how can i say this tactfully i think it
will not help the president's legacy
but donald trump is preoccupied with
future proofing not
legacy carving convinced he'll be proved
right in the end
we will win he tweeted we're making big
progress
results start to come in next week make
america
great again and with the world watching
his man in charge of pushing other
nations to accept free and fair
elections
said this there will be a smooth
transition to a second trump
administration
all right we're ready the world is
watching what's taking place here we're
gonna count all the votes
when the process is complete there'll be
electors selected there's a process the
constitution lays it out pretty clearly
partisan barb or serious statement
other senior republicans are also
shrugging off mounting calls for a
concession
supporting the president's legal fights
it's not unusual it should not be
alarming
at some point here we'll find out
finally
who was certified in each of these
states but some
constitutional experts say the
challenges are dead on arrival
he needs to overturn the results in
three states the margins aren't even
close
the legal claims aren't even close
there's zero evidence of fraud so far
this is all politics it has nothing to
do with actual law
it is four years ago to the day we
witnessed a very different transition
my number one priority in the coming
two months is to try to facilitate
a transition that ensures our
president-elect is successful
now it's not succession we're seeing but
an
escalating standoff cordelia lynch
sky news washington